[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres falten brot
was ihr zum beispiel zum grillen ganz
gut zubereiten könnte eine kräuterbutter
mache ich noch dazu und das ganze mache
ich jetzt aus einem schönen hefeteig
dabei fielen momentan das mehl knapp ist
habe ich auch einen vorschlag ihr könnt
nämlich auch ganz gut brot
backmischungen dafür verwenden entweder
haben wir hier die brotbox mischungen
dies beim lidl gibt für uns da könnte
zum beispiel das kartoffelbrot oder das
weizen brot nehmen das richtig gut weil
es vor allem zum einen sekt auf gc
lecker schmeckt da sind kartoffeln
flocken mit dabei das ist auch so dass
lieblings brot von sanierer und l&s
weizenbrot ist sowieso so gedacht dass
man da zum beispiel auch mediterrane
zutaten rhein geben kann ist außer
lecker oder ihr könnt auch einfach die
ganz die anderen brot mischung nimmt zum
beispiel code nummer zwei ist ein
dinkelbrot nummer drei sind dunkleres
brot brot 5 ist auch ganz gut aber auch
die nummer 6 also da könnte einfach
alles was nicht unbedingt ein körnerbrot
ist kann man eben ganz gut verwenden um
auch mal brötchen hier raus zu backen
oder eben einem baguette oder auch mal
entfalten so wie ich jetzt heute und aus
körnerbrot könnte auch ganz gut brötchen
formen oder auch ein baguette aber wie
gesagt für dieses falten brot für dieses
zubrot eignen sich so die helleren
bisschen besser ich zeige euch jetzt
trotzdem mal kurz die standard zutaten
falls ihr habt nehmt ihr einfach
normales mail ansonsten weg sagt einfach
eine backmischung ich verwende jetzt
dafür einen würfel hefe einen esslöffel
dattel sirup oder zucker könnt ihr auch
nehmen 250 gramm wasser darf gern warm
sein 500 kamel 50 gramm olivenöl und
zwei teelöffel salz und im prinzip ist
alles ganz einfach hefe dattel sirup
oder zucker und wasser kommen erstmal in
eine große schüssel
[Musik]
hier könnte die zutaten schon mal schön
vermischen damit sich die hefe gut
auflöst
[Musik]
es gibt jetzt noch das mehl dazu öl und
salz
[Musik]
und seht ihr daraus einfach einen
schönen geschmeidigen hefeteig entweder
mit den händen oder mit der
küchenmaschine zehn minuten ungefähr
nach der stufe 2 gebe auch schon mal
hitze dazu dann kann der tag schon mal
schön aufwärmen und geht dann eben
später auch viel schneller
[Musik]
perfekt der hefeteig super und jetzt
könnt ihr ihn einfach in der
rührschüssel lassen so ein bisschen zu
einer kugel formen am besten vorher
und dann lass ihn entweder hinter kennt
darauf gehen da hat es auch die 34 grad
oder bei der stufe im backofen oder auch
einfach schön abdecken und an der
oberfläche am besten aber mit ein
bisschen olivenöl einstreichen damit er
an der oberfläche nicht trocknet
[Musik]
der hefeteig noch auf geht werde ich
schon mal die kräuterbutter herstellen
und für die kräuterbutter nehmen die
einen kräuter die ihr kann da habt oder
einfach verschiedene kräuter aus eurem
hochbeet oder aus dem garten und
ich nehme jetzt hier welche aus dem
vorgarten und gehen oder nach hinten in
meinem hochbeet wenn es mich bis dahin
nicht weggeht eigentlich weil grad echt
die sonne dann 32 grad angesagt aber
naja oregano bissle rosmarin davon habe
ich noch salbei ich hab ich noch zehn
jahren dahinter aber im moment
petersilie ich nehme jetzt alles was
schön zusammen passt so bislang
mediterrane kräuter
[Musik]
sobald du hast mir vorbei macht so
ruhig dass eine frau ist das etwa meine
ich dass meine frau nie erlebt einfach
an mir vorbei und dann liebt mich er
liebt mich nicht
er liebt mich er liebt mich nicht er
liebt mich er liebt mich nicht erlebt
ich mich nicht erlebt nicht
[Musik]
also habe ich jetzt hier die zutaten für
die kräuterbutter nämlich 100 gramm
weiche butter eine knoblauchzehe etwas
salz und pfeffer und hier die
ausgesuchten kräuter ich habe mir den
knoblauch etwas rosmarin oregano thymian
minze salbei blätter und petersilie
jetzt sehr klein als er die kräuter und
wie gesagt ihr könnt ja kräuter nehmen
die ihr gerne mögt oder die ihr gerade
da habt schöne frische kräuter einfach
immer perfekt ihr könnt jetzt entweder
hier abzupfen vom stil und dann mit dem
messer zerkleinert also klein hacken
oder einfach in den mixer und ich mach
das jetzt hier und die dicken stile
nämlich weg und die etwas dünneren
weichen die lasse ich einfach dran
gerade bei der petersilie muss ich sagen
die kommen bei sun hochrhein
[Musik]
und jetzt hier die kräuter schön
zerkleinern
[Musik]
wenn die kräuter zerkleinert sind kommt
jetzt die knoblauchzehe noch dazu
die auch noch schön verkleinern oder
dazu reiben
[Musik]
und wenn dann alles schön zerkleinert
ist könnt ihr jetzt die klinge
herausnehmen und den schmetterlings
einsatz rein geben und damit könnte da
nämlich auch die butter schön einrühren
und dann vermischt sich eben alles gut
[Musik]
das war es schon
ihr seht da brauchen wir nicht nur 23
bewegungen und schon ist fertig und
falls sie auch den speed gehabt dann
bitte immer darauf achten das ist auch
beim bei der salatschleuder so dass es
ein seilzug dran das tolle dass man die
praktisch ohne strom benutzen kann und
wirklich überall auch im garten draußen
benutzen kann und wichtig ist dass
dieser sein zug einfach nicht nass wird
das heißt das nicht und da spielen also
nicht beim spielen unter wasser halten
sondern hier einfach schön mit einem
sauberen taschentuch oder mit einem
schwamm sauber reinigen und einfach
gucken dass die oberfläche hier nass
wird ich finde ihn halt schon immer
praktisch gerade so dips macht und da
mal was in kleiner menge zerkleinern
möchte nüsse oder auch andere sachen oft
bisschen rutschig die boote dann kann
man immer das schön ganz ohne strom
machen und vor allem können die kinder
da halt auch mithelfen ok dann habe ich
hier die kräuterbutter fertig
die können der theoretisch sogar darin
aufbewahren da gibt es noch einen deckel
dafür aber ich bin jetzt gleich das
heißt ich war kurz aufholen silicon back
matte und dann wird es zu rot stellt
ganz schnell
nehme ich jetzt hier meinen hefeteig
raus eigentlich wäre richtig schön
dieses zubrot raus auf dem grill
zubereiten aber tatsächlich ist bei uns
karte so stürmisch ist draußen hat eben
schien die sonne hat man echt glück mit
den kräutern
sonst wer jetzt hier alles zur last
dann den teig ich gucke immer beim teig
je nachdem ob ich ihnen bei der stufe
aufgehen lassen oder auch mal hier bei
raumtemperatur oder in der kern wird
wenn er noch so ein bisschen feucht ist
dann nehme ich ein bisschen mehr mühe
beim ausrollen ansonsten reicht aber
auch tatsächlich also auf der silikon
matte bleibt da echt nichts kleben da
reicht auch meist sogar ohne mehl oder
mit ganz wenig mehl aber da guckt da
einfach so wissel immer nach der teig
konsistenz an sich das muss man immer so
wissel individuell entscheiden er soll
hat trocken werden aber wie gesagt auch
nicht so feucht sein jetzt einfach zu
einem großen schönen rechteck ausrollen
[Musik]
die dünner teig jetzt ist umso mehr
schichten habt ihr auch später im brot
also ich habe das jetzt hier so ungefähr
40 x 50 cm groß
muss auch nicht perfekt rechteckig sein
aber ich ziehe den immer ganz gern
hefeteig bisher immer ganz easy und dann
einfach die kräuterbutter drauf geben
und schön verstreichen
[Musik]
da könnte jetzt den teig in streifen zu
schneiden falls sie auch auf das silikon
mutter arbeitet auf jeden fall darauf
achten dass das messer stumpf ist ich
nehme da immer gerne dieses marzipan
messer oder ihr nehmt es einfach von der
matte runter und dann so etwa
im sex streifen unter normal halbieren
[Musik]
dann nämlich jetzt zählen der backform
ich hab jetzt hier meine mama brot
backform was eckig ist schön aber ihr
könnt doch gerne runde backform nehmen
hauptsache sie es oben geeignet und
dibaba form die gusseisen form ist sogar
vom grill geeignet dazu falls ihr dann
doch das brot auf dem grill zubereiten
wollt könnt ihr das gerne in gusseisen
machen jetzt kurz ein springen mit
backtracks spray oder mit olivenöl
einpinseln
oder butter
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr die zum beispiel hier
so
ziehharmonika mäßig fünf zurechtlegen
also einfach ein bisschen falten ich
nehme meistens deswegen halte ich das
hier auch einfach das obere ende sie ist
hoch und dann legt sich das so und dann
habe ich so drei schichten
[Musik]
und dann legt die idee gerne so ein
bisschen übereinander und entweder so
dass praktisch diese falten alle oben
sind das ist immer so geschlängelt ist
oder ihr könnt auch kreuz und quer legen
wir wollen dass wir es haben möchte ich
pass auf jeden fall auf dass eine
geschlossene seite hier außen und die
andere hier außen ist und der rest des
in
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt hier den deckel drauf
und ich stelle das ganze jetzt so in den
kalten backofen heizt dann den ofen auf
180 grad ober unterhitze und dadurch
dass der backofen dann auch noch schön
aufheizt kann er der hefeteig noch gut
aufgehen alternativ könnt ihr das ganze
jetzt auch abgedeckt bei raumtemperatur
eine halbe stunde stehen lassen und
später im heißen ofen backen und so wie
ihr möchtet und ich pack das ganze
erstmal mit deckel denn der gruss
eisenblätter der dient ja praktisch oder
der funktioniert wie so ein dampfbad
offen das heißt die feuchtigkeit aus dem
teig die tritt dann aus sammelt sich am
deckel und da sind diese kleinen noppen
dran hier und dann tropft das ganze
wieder aufs brot runter das heißt ich
habe die feuchtigkeit die ganze zeit im
brot drin und später werde ich dann
einfach ohne deckel das ganze fertig
backen damit eben noch mal eine schöne
kruste bekommt so habt ihr immer den
vorteil dass alles was mit dampf packt
gerade hier führt einfach schön saftig
ist schön voluminös aufgeht und eben
nicht austrocknen
[Musik]
dann den deckel unternehmen und schön
fertig backen
[Musik]
schön sieht aus wie ein kräuter zu wort
ich würde sagen ja und ihr dürft jetzt
mal probieren
richtig gut hallo ich
habe es bislang abkühlen lassen sonst
könnte ich den top nämlich nicht
anfassen und das dann zu wenn man das
einfach hier weg ich habe ja ich auch
hier sonst verteile
meine mama liebt das auch so sehr guck
mal wieder
alles offen gab es
gar nichts dazu
gereicht aber auch die runden so richtig
gerade dazu ist er ein bisschen gemüse
so ich finde der profi könnte jetzt noch
hergehen und zwischen die einzelnen
schichten noch käse machen und dann so
den runde ja denn katar denke
dass man auf jeden fall auch mal also
falls ihr das rezept gerne mal
ausprobieren wollt ich hatte auch mal
ganz ganz ganz lange her nur altes
rezept auf meinem kanal von falten brot
ist aber stimmt acht oder zehn jahre her
also schon wieso alt habe mir gedacht
kommen wir müssen normalen falten broten
kräuter zu brot neu verfilmen und vor
allem die kräuterbutter thematisch auch
noch mal extra hoch denn die könnte er
zu allem reichen also auch mal zum steak
oder zu gemüse und wenn man
kräuterbutter da hat dann kann man sowas
immer schnell machen
ja also viel spaß beim pakt bis zum
nächsten mal ist auch richtig schade
jetzt kommt noch mal die sonne raus und
jetzt hätte ich auch draußen grillen
können aber naja
[Musik]